so we return now to our top story yeah
State lawmakers really burning the
midnight oil here trying to figure out
if they should actually help the A's
come to Las Vegas with some money let's
check in with Sasha Denise and Brian
people passionate on both sides of this
many state senators pushing back during
tonight's special session asking Those
Behind the a stadium Bill if this amount
of money is worth it
we have to do our due diligence
because this is a lot of money Nevada
state senators asking tough questions
while contemplating funding for the a
stadium is it reasonable to assume that
the A's will triple its attendance the
analysis that's being done suggests that
they will go from where they are today
which for the record is dead last right
to something that's in the 50th
percentile there are so many holes in
what the A's are trying to sell us a
special session was called to discuss a
bill Paving the way to build a 1.5
billion dollar ballpark at the current
site of the Tropicana the team would put
up a billion of that cost but 180
million dollars would come from state
tax credits with Clark County putting up
a bond for 120 million that would be
paid back by Stadium generated money the
momentum that we have in becoming the
sports and entertainment capital of the
world this is another huge step those
behind it say it would boost job
creation and entice more out of State
Travelers I think that you've done a
very good job of minimizing the risk to
the taxpayers but many senators pushed
back against the plan will you commit to
paying the equity issue that we see
existence for the live entertainment
type the the legislation as it's
currently envisioned you know does not
contemplate that the project is based on
you know what is currently proposed and
so we we've been focusing on that as
really the path forward uh for the team
and for the community can you explain to
me why we need to provide hundreds of
millions of dollars for a billionaire
billionaire team to come to the Las
Vegas Strip
on some of the most valuable property in
the world if we can't provide funding
for critical resources like summer
school and Healthcare making sure no
matter which direction they go they've
exhausted the questions our state and
community may have my concern and my
hesitation
is based upon the lack of certainty
now if this passes through the state
senate then it will go through the same
process and the assembly many members of
the community also participated in
public comment those for the bill spoke
on its benefits for construction jobs
Brian Sasha another Senator asking if
there would be any way this deal could
raise property taxes Steve Hill of the
LBC VA said it would take a quote
Armageddon scenario for this to happen
saying it's possible but extremely
unlikely